in the words of daddy yankee reggaeton
it's true I got Tony sex
but I got Tony's the struggle and
reggaeton is everywhere
[Music]
most of the names that are associated
with reggaeton are male thank J Balvin
daddy yankee gente de zona Gianni Lenox
that bunny I think that women have been
pretty under represented and triggered
on I think it's also important to
understand that reggaeton does not
operate in a vacuum but women like Evie
Queen Lisa M glory
DJ Ben Bona DJ do Bamba tamasa Del Rio
have been a part of the scene and are
among those trying to change it and its
image and it's always been a boys club
and it still is but I feel like with
that what a woman that's breaking
through to pull in other woman savvy
like this could be we can all be queens
we can all share that space hey guys
it's Sona and this week we're gonna talk
a bit about what it means to be a woman
in the reggaeton scene and how that's
changing
[Music]
in a recent episode we looked at the
roots of reggaeton talking to pioneer
scholars and innovators about how one of
the most popular music genres has
evolved over the last 35 years reggaeton
went from being a musical expression
from the kiss sitios of Puerto Rico
which in make an imp and Amenia notes to
now having its base rhythm known as
Dembo being used in songs that have
blown up on the charts but despite its
success reggaeton has a reputation for
being really macho and hyper sexualizing
women women are usually presented in
music videos and on album covers as
scantily clad models often faceless when
they're singing they're usually voices
in the background exclaiming sexualized
phrases like AI papi or offering
sexualized hooks for the songs like
glory and dawn Omar's classic hit doll
Eden Valley there are a lot of songs and
certainly a lot of videos you know
portraying women essentially as sex
objects for the stars of the genre
that's the music historian Wayne
Marshall and he says that the hyper
sexualization of women isn't just a
problem in reggaeton no that's not
terribly exceptional in the world of
popular music
so without excusing it I will just point
out that those same depictions can be
found in rap videos and rock videos and
salsa videos and Latin pop videos and
just you know you name it while
Marshalls right that the hyper
sexualization of women in reggaeton
isn't unique to the genre reggaeton has
been targeted in the 90s and early 2000s
the Puerto Rican government targeted
reggaeton and in 2002 it led an anti
pornography campaign that focused
largely on reggaeton music videos in
addition to Puerto Rico being a pretty
religious Society DJ Obama points out
that it's hard to ignore the role that
race and class have played in condemning
reggaeton as obscene of pornographic
music I think that racism gets coded as
classism
you know diaspora communities and so
when I've heard drag it's only be
stigmatizing the past it's been like oh
no that's like hood music or that's like
low class or whatever and it's a come-on
like what are you really getting at here
and like the roots of Dragonstone are in
black communities but that doesn't mean
there aren't problems in regular tones
depictions of women as petrova very Joe
who focus on race and pop culture points
out I think at the same time that some
artists or some songs might be
contesting racism they can also
reproduce the objectification of women
we have to acknowledge the kind of
positive aspects of the music so ways
that it has provided a space to talk
about some forms of inequality but also
the ways that it has reproduced other
forms of inequality but those depictions
shouldn't erase the role of women in
reggae tones history and evolution
recently now there's been like a whole
movement of feminine energy that's
coming into and it's always been around
I mean we've had people like beyond EB
Queen has been that our legends has been
killing the game take for example women
like Lassiter visa ez Queen Lisa M glory
jenny less sex Evo's latter Evita was a
Panamanian reggae and espanol artists
also known as weed girl concerned a
pioneer for women in the sound that
would later develop as reggaeton both
Gloria and Jenny less sexy voice while
reggaeton artists in their own right
provided the vocals for some of the most
well known reggaeton hooks
[Music]
despite that they both had not only a
difficult time breaking into the
mainstream but sometimes didn't even get
credit for their work then there's Lisa
M who's been referred to as Latvian era
or the pioneer for her role in
developing and raising the platform of
land wrap she's considered one of the
first female Latin rappers then there's
the only reggaeton artist to reach a
success of her male counterparts in the
early 2000s EB queen bee queen joined
Porto Rican reggaeton collective the
noise in 1995 and quickly became a force
to be reckoned with
she went on to have a successful solo
career known for turning the machismo
reggaeton was known for on its head
she's very talented artist who has had a
very long career that has kind of
spanned almost the entire history of
cricket on and I think a lot of that has
to do with her talent as a rapper and
her ability to continuously create this
innovative and musical styles and in a
May 2018 interview with romesco TV queen
characterized her legacy as talking
about empowerment on reggaeton was
talking about women and their butts and
it was her 2003 hit quiero bailar that
became an empowerment anthem for talking
about sexual consent in fact the entire
basis of the song is about a guy
expecting sex from a woman after a night
of dancing and that's just not how it
works buddy
that song would go on to become an
integral part of the mainstreaming of
reggaeton in the early 2000s but both DJ
Rio Bamba and DJ been Bona who are new
york-based Latinas DJs and the first to
play reggaeton in New York's renowned
boiler-room Club point out how
traditionally only one woman has been
allowed a space in the mainstream
reggaeton scene others just relegated to
hooks may be clean right queen singular
because there's one woman who's allowed
to have that place you know are like
there are the hooks on the tracks of
like glory or Jenny less sexy ball so
you hear like a little snippet but it
was always like a really marginalized
paint place but this is changing with
more women coming into the reggaeton
scene an example of a woman making waves
recently and controversially is Chilean
neo pedal artist - masa DeLeon tamasa
del Rio is a tattoo artist turned
reggaeton performer known for her
sexually graphic lyrics and because of
her centric of women's sexuality and her
music she's been heralded as taking
reggaeton into its next phase one led by
women like the sexual nature of the
music and like the way that woman are
talked about like I play those chances
I'm gonna stand in front of it and be
like I'm not supposed to be here like
I'm not supposed to take up this space
but like I'm gonna reclaim that space in
the club and the way that like this was
never intended to be while there's still
a lot of debate on exactly what sexual
agency and empowerment looks like in the
reggaeton seen Marshall points out that
it's important to treat the genre like
any other genre reggaeton deserves as
much of a chance and there's much a sort
of sense of of scrutiny and and kind of
getting a sense of what what you like
there and what you don't as any
so with reggaeton back in the mainstream
the genre is ripe for having its
direction changed especially by women
hey guys don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and let us know in the
comments who your favorite reggaeton
artists are especially women artists